de una manera importante que tienen los
maestros para potenciar una mentalidad
de crecimiento es ayudar a los
estudiantes a reflexionar en su propio
aprendizaje en las actividades de
campeonato intentamos deliberadamente
dar mucho espacio para que los
estudiantes se involucren en la
autorreflexión y uno de los objetivos de
hacer esto es ayudar a los maestros a
crear un ambiente realmente auto
reflexivo y comenzar el año escolar de
esta manera y esperamos que sea algo que
pueda mantenerse durante el resto del
año es muy fácil aprender muchas cosas y
no darnos cuenta de lo que estamos
aprendiendo
si no hay autorreflexión la
autorreflexión realmente nos ayuda a
reconocer lo que estamos haciendo y
conectarlo con la razón por la que lo
estamos haciendo también nos ayuda a
interiorizar ciertas ideas de manera más
profunda cuando los maestros ayudan a
los alumnos a reflexionar sobre su
propio aprendizaje estos últimos pueden
pensar en las metas que tienen para ese
aprendizaje y a medida que vayan
alcanzando estas metas
si los estudiantes reflexionan en eso y
las ven como parte de su propia
trayectoria de crecimiento les ayudarán
a alcanzar lo que buscan ya sea una
buena calificación o convertirse en
mejores escritores o mejores matemáticos
y esto a la larga le resulta estimulante
y les ayudan a ver que realmente están
avanzando en esa trayectoria esto es más
motivante que simplemente hacer cosas
que no parecen estar relacionadas unas
con otras
creo que una forma particularmente
importante más de autorreflexión es
cuando los estudiantes escuchen a sus
maestros a sus compañeros oa sí mismos
reflexionar acerca de cómo las
dificultades los han ayudado a mejorar
esto puede ser un buen recordatorio de
que las dificultades no son el punto
final de algo un problema no significa
que debamos renunciar o que no tenemos
madera para hacer algo por el contrario
si usamos las estrategias correctas y
perseveramos y quizá buscamos ayuda de
otros vamos a superar las dificultades y
convertirnos en mejores estudiantes o
mejores matemáticos
o lo que sea mejores patinadores mejores
en lo que sea que implique esa tarea